you know some of these Niche subjects
like critical the word is Niche sir
Niche Ace Theory other types of D Niche
E.I infused uh courses and Majors
um Florida's getting out of that game
um if you want to do things like uh
gender ideology uh go to Berkeley go to
some of these other places that's fine
it's fine yeah and by the way I
understand that both both Niche and
Niche are acceptable pronunciations in
2023 for that word uh that we people
have the country has been pulled okay
and it's not at all evident that just
because Junkin won in Virginia on this
uh you know anti-anti woke campaign
platform uh and because DeSantis did
well in Florida it is not at all clear
that that is going to win you a
presidential election